First violent to me if
I was interested for me.
And so when we have in stealing,
killing cops,
everything,
drugs taken jubilee project to
the next level for the stores,
we still believe that doing good
is contagious. It's still hard.
So have the portable son has always been,
I grew up listening to
the story at church,
but it never really hit me until
I started making this film.
How do the sun is such a profound story?
Something that I could really relate
with is probably one of the most intimate
passages of scripture in all the Bible.
And what you have is a son who
is pretty arrogant and he says,
give me my inheritance or giving
me what I, what I deserve.
And so when he said that in a
minute needed Mideastern culture,
he was basically saying,
I wish you were dead.
So just give me the money problem,
challenge
Shane and his father around and trying
to make his own way to still know his
dad's money. And what's crazy is
the father gave him be heretics.
Knowing Kali,
that the sandwich squander all the Laos
and in the Senate of course goes off and
there's this crazy life,
this takes waste.
All the money just really lives in the
world and ends up finding that it's a
pretty cool place.
The turning point in the film is when
the sun reaches this utter sense of
hopelessness when he's got nothing left,
spent all the money and there's nothing
in this world that satisfies and it's
when he's in this deep sense of pain
that he starts to let go of this need for
what the world tells him to have.
And so this is then part where he knows
that he has to make a change for the
better or a better life, a different life,
and leave the one that he's been doing.
Huh?
And he said it'd be better if he goes
back home and he goes back home broken.
So you see him totally open
and obedient to his father.
But what was cool was this,
the father saw his son from a fire and
I love the picture of this like Mid
Eastern Asian type of dad
running towards the Sun.
And then it says he embraces
him and he kisses him.
And this is the most powerful verse to me.
Like we're kissing is used over and over
again, or it's in the iterative sense.
So it's like he kissed him over
and over and over and over.
It's showing this blessing,
this grace
3.1.
This is one where I really was able to
connect to the character after the part
of the son's story is like, you know,
one of the most popular stories, average.
A lot of people can relate to it
and we've all been there. I've
been in the sun and the farm,
I can relate to the room and just having
neck stage of rebellion and he's not
like realizing how much their parents
love them and always wanting something
else. And then finding out
that that somebody else is
not good, not good. Anyways,
my parents divorced when I was
a teenager, when I was about 15 and it
was a result and under fair my dad had.
And I hate it. My Dad, in fact,
I didn't want to talk to him
and I didn't for a long time.
And, uh, so I,
I kind of spiraled out of control where
I just partied and I did my own thing.
So, you know, fast forward some,
I still had problems with my dad.
You know,
I'd give my life to God.
It's supposed to be like this now
Christian Guy that really loves God.
But I had this like hatred from my father.
I couldn't,
I this judgement against
him even though myself,
I'd done crazy stupid thing. I
couldn't see that. I just saw his sin.
And so that dominated me until one night
I was walking across the campus as a
college student and I thought,
I heard a voice saying,
you need to love your
father. And I said, uh,
I don't think I can because
I have no feelings for him.
And I felt God say,
you think my son's felt
like going to the cross.
Then I got it. I said, love
is not about a feeling.
Love is about commitment. It's not
about me liking a person necessarily.
It's about me committing myself to one.
It took me about a year and a half to
make this film and I kind of wrote it, um,
when I was a very different
person than I am today.
I think the main difference between
then and now was that I started to
understand what it means to receive grace.
Throughout my whole life, I've
always, I've always lived on there,
this belief that the harder I
worked and why I'm able to achieve,
and then the more happy I'm able
to become. And so I worked hard.
I went to great college
at Harvard University.
I achieved my American dream
of working at the White House.
I was living a very comfortable life
and yet there was still something empty
about this whole thing. No matter how
hard I tried to put up this front,
to put up this image that
everything was all that together.
Deep down inside I realized I still felt
like life was still very meanings to
me.
And no matter how much harder I work,
the harder I tried. There was still
this very strong void in my life.
I felt so depressed.
I felt so exhausted and I hit the rock
bottom of my life and there was one night
where I just felt completely
all the simpler where I
thought about taking my own
life.
During that season of depression,
I was diagnosed with a
disease called hepatitis B,
and when I first found out about it,
um,
I was in utter shock.
I felt so paralyzed by this point,
with this understanding that this
realization that the greats Eddie lead,
the great person that I thought I was
wasn't really as great as I really was.
And it was in that moment of revelation
that I started to see that my life was
only so temporary.
I am weak then I am broken.
I am full of sin.
That there was nothing in me that
inherently maybe deserves and slot.
Wait,
you gave it to me anyways.
It was only in this moment of weakness
did I start to finally understand what
the power of the father's
love really means to us.
It's the most powerful expression
of love that you can ever experience
and action you.
Dave,
I really believe that this story,
look 15 isn't really adopt the sun.
It's really all about the fog.
It's about how loving and gracious
he was to this rebellious time.
Interesting thing about the story is
that, you know, we focus on son's journey.
Let me see his suffering.
You see the fact that she becomes
homeless and this is office money.
But what we don't is that this father
is also suffering. That's from,
of course,
he's a loving father and it tears him
up inside just watching his son destroy
himself.
The reason why the father's paying
assault salt pork sun only realizes the
father's love,
the father's name,
what a father can give for his son in
order to teach him the life lesson.
We don't realize it until later on, but
you know, the whole life journey is to,
to find ourselves through our hardships.
I made a lot of mistakes in life and uh,
it's good to know that no matter,
no matter how many mistakes you made,
there's always somebody who
willing to still accept you.
Forgive him.
I'm lucky enough to happen.
Given the second chance to know what
makes a story so powerful is the reality
that at the end of the day,
the sun never really did spot,
but the father chose to die for his
son because his love for him was really
unconditional.
It's the expression of love.
It's an expression of selflessness
or selfless, seemingly foolish,
so many truly radical,
truly life changing.
And what we hope that people will take
away from this film is this idea that
that love is still today and that will
be able to experience that love even just
cuts a piece of that love.
Your lights will be so much.
Yeah, I know how to
take care of babies. No,
we'd have to make a cameo in there.
We do videos. You've got to look at
the prodigal to bleed project.
We're very excited to announce a national
tour in 2014 to premiere some of our
upcoming videos and on this tour we'll
also be sharing our personal story behind
jubilee project and what inspires
us to do what we do. That's right.
So if you want updates on the tour or
if you want us to come to your score or
your church started as 2014 tour,
please sign up at this link.
We hope to hear from you soon.
And Jp love.